Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Julia.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, Folge dreihundertdreiundneunzig aufgezeichnet am einundzwanzigsten Mai.
Zwanzig einundzwanzig, ein Tag nachdem die EU-Urheberrechtsreform,
ein deutsches EU-Urheberrechtsreformgesetz überführt wurde und das
setzt einem langen Lied, das seit zwanzig dreizehn gesungen wird, ein Ende
Zwanzig, dreizehn, da war, das ist so lange her, da war Julia Reeder noch nicht einmal im EU-Parlament.
So lange ist das her ähm und Julia Reeder hat dieses äh diese äh diese Gesetzgebungsprozess auf der EU-Ebene ja maßgeblich äh begleitet und gestaltet als die,
Berichterstatterin des E
U-Parlaments, wenn ich das jetzt richtig gesagt habe. Und jetzt inzwischen ist sie äh aus freien Stücken hat sie sich aus der, aus der parlamentarischen Politik zurückgezogen, ist jetzt bei der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte und.
Ist natürlich die einzige Person, die für Lokbuchnetzpolitik in Frage kommt, um sie jetzt mal.
Zu diesem Thema zu befragen. Julia, es ist äh ziemlich genau oder etwas über drei Monate her, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Da warst du.
Zuletzt bei uns zu Gast. Da wurde das gerade so über, da da fing die Debatte in Deutschland an über die Umsetzung. Habe ich das richtig in Erinnerung?
Ja genau, also da hatte das äh Kabinett, also die Bundesregierung, gerade seinen Gesetzesentwurf verabschiedet und ähm.
Ja, über diesen Gesetzesentwurf hat jetzt der Bundestag, also wenn wir aufnehmen gestern, ähm,
in veränderter Form äh abgestimmt. Also das heißt, äh die Urheberrechtsreform ist jetzt verabschiedet, also formal,
muss noch der Bundesrat zustimmen und äh der Bundespräsident unterschreiben, aber im Grunde genommen ist äh das Ding jetzt gegessen und ähm es gab also seit wir das letzte Mal gesprochen haben, noch ein paar,
Detailänderung am Gesetzestext, aber was wir jetzt eben wissen, ist die Uploadfilter kommen.
Und zwar gültig zum ersten August werden die verpflichtend für Plattformen in Deutschland.
Oh, das ist ja relativ zügig, oder?
Das ist sehr zügig. Also es ist äh,
quasi durch den Bundestag noch so 'ne Gnadenfrist in dieses Gesetz reingeschrieben worden, weil eigentlich tritt der Artikel siebzehn schon am
in Kraft, aber da haben sie dann wirklich gesagt, also beim allerbesten Willen werden es die Plattformen wahrscheinlich nicht schaffen, neue Funktionen mit,
äh für diese mutmaßlich erlaubten
Nutzung, also die Unterscheidung in fünfzehn Sekunden Schnipsel und hundertsechzig Zeichen Schnipsel und so weiter. Das alles jetzt irgendwie innerhalb von zwei Wochen einzuprogrammieren, also hat man sich gesagt, geben wir ihnen fünf Wochen
Und äh das muss jetzt anscheinend reichen. Also das heißt, es ist äh ein kleines bisschen später, das in Kraft,
als ursprünglich geplant war, aber natürlich trotzdem immer noch unglaublich schnell. Also das quasi ein Gesetz, das vor wo vor drei Tagen
der Text noch nicht feststand
in in knapp zwei Monaten eben Anwendung finden wird für Plattformen in Deutschland ist schon ziemlich sportlich würde ich sagen.
Jetzt, jetzt tust du so, als wäre aber der größere Teil des Textes, der war ja schon irgendwie klar oder? Also es ist ja vielleicht musst du nochmal, also man kann's ja nicht oft genug wiederholen. Es ist eine EU.
Verordnung.
Nee, Richtlinie, also das heißt.
Die das heißt also Deutschland muss quasi die Details selber regeln und deshalb gab's jetzt auch nochmal so große Diskussionen, also bei Verordnung ist es ja andersrum, da gilt quasi das EU-Gesetz unmittelbar in Deutschland.
Okay, genau, also mit der die EU verordnet, so sei es und mit einer Richtlinie wird gesagt, so.
In diesem Rahmen haben sich bitte die Mitgliedstaaten zu bewegen.
Um hier halbwegs äh einheitlichkeit äh im im Rechtsgeschehen zu haben für für Menschen, die sich in der EU äh bewegen.
Genau, also Richtlinien haben den Vorteil für die EU, dass die da mehr oder weniger wünscht dir was, spielen kann und das hat sie eben bei Artikel siebzehn besonders äh ausgiebig gemacht, indem sie einfach gesagt
äh wir wünschen uns,
ihr Mitgliedstaaten sicherstellt, dass äh alle Urheberrechtsverletzungen automatisch gesperrt werden und alle legalen Inhalte online bleiben. Und wie das in der Praxis funktionieren soll,
Das könnt ihr euch dann in eurer nationalen Umsetzung überlegen. Also das war die Ausgangsposition. Natürlich äh für alle, die ein bisschen was von der Technik der Uploadfilter verstehen,
eine, ja, praktisch unlösbare Aufgabe.
Wie ist das denn ähm,
in anderen Ländern gelaufen. Das habe ich äh zugegebenermaßen gar nicht so genau verfolgt. Wir haben die ähm haben die da auch so so viel
oder ähm gibt es da jetzt überhaupt großartige Abweichungen, weil die die Hoffnung einer Richtlinie wäre ja wahrscheinlich schon, dass es irgendwie eine Einheitlichkeit gibt, aber es klingt gerade so, als könnten hier,
elementare ähm ja Variablen in dieser Einheitlichkeit dann doch noch von jedem einzelnen Mitgliedsstaat bestimmt werden.
Also na ja, ich glaube, die meisten Mitgliedsstaaten haben's einfach gar nicht erst versucht. Also äh.
Es ist nicht ganz ungewöhnlich, dass zum
Zeitpunkt, äh wo die Richtlinie eigentlich umgesetzt sein muss, dass noch nicht alle Mitgliedsstaaten gemacht haben. Aber in diesem Fall wird's wirklich der Regelfall sein. Also am siebten Juni,
muss Artikel siebzehn eigentlich umgesetzt sein und es werden, glaube ich, so vier oder fünf Mitgliedsstaaten das tatsächlich geschafft haben,
und ähm das ist natürlich sehr, sehr wenig, das heißt also so die Frage, wie haben die anderen das gemacht, äh die häufigste Antwort wird sein, gar nicht.
Ähm.
Also noch nicht mal gar so so richtig gar nicht. So neulich.
Also,
Sie haben vielleicht angefangen, es gibt ein paar Länder, die haben irgendwie Vorschläge auf dem Tisch liegen, zum Beispiel Finnland oder äh Österreich, da gab's so erste Entwürfe
der österreichische, relativ ähnlich zum Deutschen, der Finnische ähm hat nochmal einen anderen Ansatz gewählt, aber also.
Man kann so sagen, alle Mitgliedsstaaten außer Deutschland, die schon was verabschiedet haben, die haben einfach diese zentrale Frage, wie soll das gehen, dass die legalen Inhalte online bleiben, einfach überhaupt
beantwortet, sondern die haben die Richtlinie einfach in ihre nationale Sprache übersetzt und ins Gesetz geschrieben.
Also da steht dann halt drin es darf nicht dazu kommen, dass legale Inhalte nicht äh äh nicht verfügbar sind. Also damit ist natürlich überhaupt nicht
beantwortet, wie das klappen soll. Das ist zum Beispiel in den Niederlanden oder Frankreich der Fall. Und das heißt also Deutschland sind die einzigen, die es irgendwie versucht haben. Und da kann man jetzt viel kritisieren, also dass es natürlich nicht funktioniert,
nicht funktionieren kann, aber zumindest haben sie es versucht.
Was bedeutet das, wenn man's nicht versucht, dann heißt es, es wird dann in den Gerichten geklärt oder.
Ja, aber ich glaube, in der Praxis heißt es vor allen Dingen, dass die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer den Kürzeren ziehen, weil ähm du hast ja ähm ein,
Auf der anderen Seite teilweise relativ äh große Medienunternehmen.
Und äh es gibt einen relativ etabliertes System für Schadensersatz bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen und diese Schadensersatzansprüche sind in der Regel doch relativ hoch. Das heißt also, die Plattformen wissen ungefähr,
Was passiert, wenn sie ihre Pflichten gegenüber den Rechteinhabern verletzen? Also wenn sie zu wenig sperren.
Wissen sie, sie sind direkt haftbar dafür und das heißt Schadensersatzpflichtig gegenüber diesem Rechteinhaber, die auch relativ viele Anwältinnen und Anwälte haben, das heißt,
es wird für sie potentiell teuer.
Deren Briefpapier ist auch schon gut bekannt, ne? Das.
Genau, genau, also da wissen sie, womit sie rechnen müssen. Und auf der anderen Seite steht halt im Gesetz, ja, ihr dürft aber auch nicht die Rechte der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer verletzen.
Und wenn ihr es doch tut.
Tja, weiß man nicht, was passiert. Also das heißt, auf der einen Seite ist die Chance, dass einzelne Nutzerinnen und Nutzer klagen sehr viel geringer und auf der anderen Seite,
ist auch sehr viel unklarer, was sie vor Gericht dann tatsächlich bekommen werden. Und das ist eine Sache,
also wo wir auch äh von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte uns sehr dafür eingesetzt haben in Deutschland, dass das hier besser wird, also dass halt äh,
nicht einfach gesagt wird, wir überlassen das komplett den Gerichten, sondern wir versuchen ähm so ein paar Grundpfeiler.
Einzuführen, was eigentlich passiert, wenn zu viel gesperrt wird. Und das ist zumindest teilweise gut gelungen. Also es gibt jetzt in diesem Gesetzesentwurf zum Beispiel Schadensersatz
Ansprüche gegen falsche Copyright-Clans. Also das ist ja ein.
Beliebtes Problem, dass irgendjemand irgendwas auf YouTube zum Beispiel sperren lässt, der aber eigentlich gar keine Exklusivrechte, da ran hat,
Da gibt's jetzt einen Schadensersatzanspruch im Gesetz.
Ganz kurz, dass der, dass damit meinst du das Beispiel, ähm wo,
also ich glaube die die klassischen YouTube-Beispiele, die ich da kenne, ist Youtuber machen etwas, äh Fernsehsender berichten darüber und lassen dann die Originalvideos automatisiert von YouTube löschen, weil das ist ja jetzt ihr Material.
Genau, das ist so ein klassischer Fall, da weiß man auch, wer quasi die Quelle der des falschen Copyright Claims war,
dann könnte halt äh dieser YouTuber zu dem Fernsehsender hingehen und ihn auf Schadensersatz verklagen. Das ist natürlich trotzdem immer noch.
Ein Problem, weil dann ist die Frage, ja wie kann man diesen Schaden denn überhaupt beziffern? Also wenn es ein professioneller YouTuber ist, kann er vielleicht sagen, irgendwie, ich habe so und so viele Einnahmen verloren deshalb.
Aber es gibt ja auch so einen ideellen Schaden, also meine Meinungsfreiheit wird eingeschränkt. Das ist natürlich schwieriger zu beziffern, aber zumindest äh also gibt's auch solche Maßnahmen erstmal.
Und das ist jetzt, das ist also etwas, was in Deutschland eine ähm ein Ergebnis dieser Diskussionen ist.
Genau, also ich glaube, der Hauptgrund, weshalb Deutschlands sich irgendwie so viel.
Mühe gemacht hat, doch spezifische Regeln zu finden. Es war halt doch die Aufmerksamkeit auch viel größer ist. Also es,
dieses Versprechen von der Bundesregierung, wir setzen das komplett ohne Uploadfilter um. Das hat natürlich nicht funktioniert,
Dann gab's zumindest noch irgendwie die Ambition, wir wollen möglichst wenig äh Overblocking, also möglichst wenige Fälle, wo legale Inhalte,
werden und dann gab's auch diese Protokolleerklärung, die Deutschland verabschiedet hat, das heißt, es war zumindest mal klar,
dass sie es sich nicht erlauben können, einfach nur eins zu eins den Text von Artikel siebzehn abzuschreiben ohne irgendwelche dieser offenen Fragen zu beantworten. Und dadurch haben wir jetzt ein relativ komplexes System,
bekommen, auch mit so ein paar Anachronisten, irgendwie die hundertsechzig Zeichen und äh solche Sachen, die man natürlich kritisieren kann,
ähm aber ich glaube, die die.
Kernproblem, also das Kernproblem, das Uploadfilter die Meinungsfreiheit einschränken und dass das Ganze für Unternehmen,
Unkalkulierbare Kosten erzeugte und das ist am Ende wahrscheinlich eher die großen Konzerne stärken wird, die schon Filter haben. All das sind einfach Probleme, die in Artikel siebzehn selber schon angelegt sind.
Und die kann so eine nationale Umsetzung glaube ich überhaupt nicht lösen.
Das äh erinnert mich an, also deswegen war ja auch der Kampf damals auf der EU-Ebene der entscheidende, weil ja allen, die mitgedacht haben, du gehörtest ja dazu, äh gesagt haben, so das kriegt man nicht mehr weggedockt heute, ne? Und das war ja auch
gehörte ja zu den
zu diesen ja doch sehr schmerzhaften Peinlichkeiten eben in der Auseinandersetzung mit Axel Voss dass er dass er sich da hingestellt hat und gesagt hat, ja nee, das muss ja, muss man ja gar nicht mit Uploadfilter machen, das muss steht ja überhaupt nicht, dass man das so machen muss und alle sagten so
wie denn sonst? Und er dann sagt, ja ich bin ja jetzt kein Experte für Internet so, ne, also das äh das kann ja die.
Es ist wirklich äh äh sehr bedauerlich. Jetzt musste man nochmal erklären, was das genau mit diesen hundertsechzig Zeichen auf sich hat.
Genau, also die, das Kernproblem in Artikel siebzehn ist ja.
Illegale Inhalte müssen gesperrt werden, legale Inhalte müssen online bleiben
und das Ganze muss irgendwie automatisch passieren können, wegen der großen Mengen von Inhalten. Aber die Uploadfilter sind halt nicht so intelligent, das heißt also irgendwie Unterscheidung zwischen einem Zitat.
Und einer Urheberrechtsverletzung kann so ein Filter nicht. Also er hat sich jetzt der deutsche Gesetzgeber überlegt, wir machen so Schwellenwerte, die Algorithmen interpretieren können.
Und nennen die mutmaßlich erlaubte Nutzung. Also das heißt, wenn,
ein Upload, diese objektiven, technischen Kriterien erfüllt, dann ist er mutmaßlich erlaubt und darf zumindest nicht automatisch gesperrt werden. Die Plattformen müssen trotzdem dafür bezahlen,
Aber zumindest wird dann halt nicht automatisch gesperrt. Und das ist halt ein Upload ähm der einmal nicht mehr als die Hälfte.
Eines geschützten Werks enthält. Also da muss man auch schon sagen, auch das ist technisch eigentlich nicht interpretierbar. Damit wird wahrscheinlich hier der Praxis gemeint sein, weniger als die Hälfte der Referenzdatei, die im Uploadfilter hinterlegt ist.
Aber das ist halt was, was ein Uploadfilter irgendwie unterscheiden kann. Da wird gesagt, dieser Inhalt muss mit anderen Inhalten kombiniert werden. Also man kann nicht einfach nur eins zu eins einen Ausschnitt aus einem Kinofilm hochladen zum Beispiel, sondern es muss irgendwie.
Andere Inhalte geben, mit denen das verbunden wird und dann gibt's eben als drittes Kriterium.
Entweder dieser Inhalt muss gekennzeichnet sein als legale Schrankennutzung, also Zitat Parodie und so weiter oder er muss geringfügig sein. Und geringfügig bedeutet halt.
Äh eine nicht-kommerzielle Nutzung von weniger als hundertsechzig Zeichentext.
Weniger als hundertfünfundzwanzig Kilobyte bei einem Bild oder weniger als fünfzehn Sekunden Video oder Audio und da merkt man halt schon.
Dass die hundert Seiten hundertsechzig Zeichentext auch im Vergleich zu den fünfzehn Sekunden oder den hundertfünfundzwanzig Kiloball einfach offensichtlich sehr viel weniger sind und das liegt halt daran, dass die Presseverlage.
Äh am längsten Hebel sitzen gegenüber der Bundesregierung, würde ich sagen.
Ich will die Kriterien nochmal kurz zusammenfassen. Also das mutmaßlich erlaubte Nutzung ist, wenn ich weniger als die Hälfte des Werkes mit etwas anderem kombiniert.
Und ähm und äh das muss ja mit was anderem kombiniert sein, ne und ähm.
Oder oder, ja genau, die Verknüpfung ist nämlich Oda, weil geringfügig oder gekennzeichnet, könnten sich ja auch für für sehr viel kürzere oder auch für vielleicht längere, nee, Quatsch, kann auch sein, ne? Also, und geringfügig oder gekennzeichnet
Also wie ist die Verknüpfung.
Genau, also das heißt, dass mit den fünfzig Prozent und das mit anderen Inhalten kombinieren, also das ist irgendwie eine Transformation sein muss, das ist immer der Fall und dann entweder geringfügig oder gekennzeichnet.
Also und, und dann in Klammern oder oder sowas, ja. Okay und jetzt und dieses geringfügig oder jetzt wäre jetzt hatte ich das mit den hundertsechzig Zeichen verstanden, als.
Also diese geringfügige Nutzung, das wäre etwas, wo man sagt, hier entfällt überhaupt die Prüfung, auch wenn es.
Nicht weniger als die Hälfte ist.
Nee, leider nicht. Das war ursprünglich mal so, aber tatsächlich, also da gab's auch äh äh wirklich großen Protest
gegenüber dem ersten Entwurf von Seiten äh ich weiß nicht, äh äh Verlegerverbänden und so weiter, die gesagt haben, aber es gibt ja Gedichte, die ganz,
sind oder es gibt äh äh Pressemeldungen, die ganz kurz sind. Und deshalb wurde dann halt noch diese Regelung mit den fünfzig Prozent eingeführt. Also das heißt, wenn du halt irgendwie ein äh ich sage mal, ein sehr kurzes Gedicht hast
dass nur hundert Zeichen lang ist, dann darfst du halt maximal fünfzig Zeichen daraus verwenden.
Ist natürlich also das wird natürlich unweigerlich zu Falls positives führen, weil ja schon zum Beispiel der Name der Urheberrechtsrichtlinie selber irgendwie zweihundertzwanzig Zeichen lang ist. Aber ähm ja, also das ist einfach eine,
relativ absurde Grenze. Und ich glaube, der einzige Grund, weshalb das vielleicht nicht,
massenhaft falschen Sperrungen führen wird, ist, weil ich glaube, dass relativ wenig gerechte Inhaber von Texten ernsthaft,
Auf Uploadfilter zurückgreifen werden. Das ist meine einzige Hoffnung an der Stelle, also wenn die das wirklich machen, was sie jetzt halt dürfen laut Gesetz und eine Sperrung von Texten verlangen,
mit Uploadfiltern, dann wird das zu massenhaft Problemen führen, weil diese hundertsechzig Zeichen einfach also weltfremd sind. Aber ich glaube, hoffentlich werden nicht so viele Leute ernsthaft Texte sperren lassen.
Finde ich gut, dass das auch nochmal in die in die Realität ziehst, aber weil was ich kenne ist, wenn ich jetzt in so einer ähm App bin oder was weiß ich oder im Browser und sage, ich möchte jetzt hier einen Artikel twittern.
Dann bieten die mir jetzt zum Beispiel an, ne Titel des Artikels und äh Link dazu oder oder noch äh womöglich noch den Teasertext, ne. Das heißt, da werden ja quasi schon Standardfunktionalitäten,
die irgendwie angeboten werden von solchen Apps würden dann zu einer Sperrung führen können, ne.
Ja vielleicht, also ich weiß nicht, ob bei so einem Standard zum Beispiel, dass bei.
Twitter eingeblendet wird, ob man da wirklich schon über hundertsechzig Zeichen kommt, aber es ist so in der ungefähren Größenordnung wahrscheinlich, ja. Also könnte passieren.
Und das das bezieht sich auch explizit auf Nachrichten, ne, also ähm ja Presseverlag.
Ja, wobei das eigentlich ähm also meiner Ansicht nach mit Artikel siebzehn eigentlich nicht vereinbar ist, weil äh Artikel siebzehn selber,
bezieht sich eigentlich gar nicht auf das Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverlage, aber das hat äh der Bundestag leider anders gemacht. Also in Deutschland gilt,
Urheberrechtsdiensteanbietergesetz mit den Upload-Filtern auch fürs Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverleger, obwohl das eigentlich in der Richtlinie anders steht.
Das werden dann wahrscheinlich irgendwann Gerichte entscheiden müssen, ob das überhaupt äh europarechtskonform ist.
Jetzt müssen wir nochmal kurz also aus der Perspektive der Nutzerinnen kommend. Ähm das bedeutet.
Aber das sind also es sind immer noch die,
die Filterregeln, die hier gelten, ne? Das heißt nicht, dass ich ins Gefängnis komme. Ich übertreibe jetzt, ne? Wenn ich wenn ich irgendwie auf Tagesschau DE, ja gut, die werden's wahrscheinlich eh nicht machen, aber auf ähm.
Bild DE.
Wenn ich wenn wenn Bild DE in meinem Netzwerk nicht gesperrt wäre und ich würde diese Seite besuchen und äh würde da irgendwie irgendeinen menschenverachtenden Unsinn ähm kopieren und twittern und und Link dazu, dann,
wäre quasi diese hundertsechzig Zeichen Grenze wäre dann relevant, wenn der Axt den Springer-Verlag gegenüber beispielsweise Twitter ähm,
sagen würde, pass auf, wenn da mehr als hundertsechzig Zeichen von unseren Hetzblättern kommen, dann äh darfst du das nicht veröffentlichen, ne? Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass ich jetzt.
Direkten Ärger mit dem Achselspringer Verlag bekäme, weil ich deren menschenverachtende Botschaften multipliziert habe. Korrekt.
Korrekt, also diese hundertsechzig Zeichen sagen nichts darüber aus, was erlaubt ist und was verboten. Da gelten immer noch die ganz normalen Regeln des Urheberrechts, die schon kompliziert genug sind, also,
zum Beispiel irgendwie Zitate, darf ich verwenden und so weiter. Ähm es ist übrigens auch noch nicht mal hundertprozentig glaube, das Gesetz überhaupt für Twitter gilt
weil ähm glücklicherweise auch äh in im deutschen Gesetz nochmal klargestellt ist, dass es irgendwie um um Plattformen geht,
die mit so Streamingdiensten konkurrieren. Und das könnte sein, dass das für Twitter als so eine hauptsächlich textbasierte.
Plattform überhaupt nicht zutrifft. Also wahrscheinlich wird's eher um YouTube, Instagram.
TikTok und so weiter gehen und um Twitter vielleicht gar nicht. Aber grundsätzlich hast du Recht, also hundertsechzig Zeichen heißt nicht, dass jetzt alles über hundertsechzig Zeichen in Zukunft illegal ist, sondern es heißt einfach nur,
egal, ob's vegan oder illegal ist, ähm unter dieser Grenze von den hundertsechzig Zeichen darf halt nicht automatisch gesperrt werden.
Okay, ähm glaubst du, dass das ein dass das mit der bei den
Also bei den Texten ja hundertsechzig Zeichen, ich finde das ich das lädt halt wirklich einfach ein,
zu so schönen Vergleichen, wie du gerade sagtest, der Name der Richtlinie ist schon länger als hundertsechzig Zeichen, ja? Als ich mir gestern die Bundestagsdebatte angeschaut habe, habe ich auch gedacht, warum fängt denn jetzt niemand seine Rede an und hört nach hundertsechzig Zeichen,
auf, um zu sagen ja, also den den Scherz hätte ich doch irgendjemanden.
Witzigerweise,
ausgerechnet an Ska Heveling, ja? Der Urheberrechts-Hardliner von der CDU hat genau diesen Witz gebracht oder so ähnlich zumindest, weil
es gab ja Proteste von den Presseverlagen noch bis zur letzten Minute, die gesagt haben, hundertsechzig Zeichen sind viel zu viel
weil äh also irgendwie auf der Webseite der ähm des äh Bundesverbands der deutschen Zeitungsverleger
irgendwie äh die Journalistin erzählen in hundertsechzig Zeichen ganze Geschichten.
Und so und dann hat tatsächlich Ansgar Hefeling, also der eigentlich immer alles das macht, was die Presseverlage äh verlangen, irgendwie in seiner Rede gesagt, so, ja, diese Rede ist jetzt übrigens schon zweitausendfünfhundert Zeichen dann,
tatsächlich, also wenn selbst Ansgar Hefeling dir sagt, dass du übertreibst, äh dann sollten sich vielleicht auch die Presseverlage mal fragen, ob sie eigentlich noch irgendeinen Bezug zur Realität haben bei ihren Forderungen. Also natürlich eine Strategie, die auf,
ne? Man verlangt irgendwie von der Politik hundertfünfzig Prozent und bekommt dann am Ende hundertzehn.
Ähm bei Audio war die Grenze wie lang, wie viel Sekunden?
Fünfzehn Sekunden.
Also ich würde sagen, in manchen Fällen kann das hilfreich sein, ne. Also dieser Klassiker, der jetzt irgendwie immer mal wieder äh äh aufgetaucht ist, Polizist spielt auf.
Demonstrationen oder während einem Livestream auf seinem Handy plötzlich Musik ab.
Um zu versuchen, damit den Livestream zu unterbrechen. Wenn man sich dann zügig von dem entfernt, dann.
Könnte das funktionieren, dass man dann halt unter dieser fünfzehn Sekunden Grenze bleibt. Also allein deshalb, glaube ich, schon superwichtig,
Natürlich gibt's aber auch legale legale Nutzung von Musik die länger als fünfzehn Sekunden sind und da muss man dann wieder selber kennzeichnen.
Über dieses Beispiel mit dem Abbrechen von Streams haben wir auch beim letzten Mal schon gesprochen, gibt es da auch überlieferte Fälle, dass es wirklich mal geklappt hat?
Geklappt nicht. Also mir ist noch ein Fall aus Frankreich bekannt,
Der war insofern interessant, dass der Polizist sich nicht entblödet hat, sogar zu sagen im Stream, warum er das macht. Also da hat er dann gesagt
ja, damit ihr Ärger mit der bekommt, also das ist die französische GEMA, funktioniert hat's, aber in dem Fall auch nicht. Und ich vermute, das liegt daran, dass die meisten Uploadfilter, die bisher im,
äh im Einsatz sind einfach nicht so scharf gestellt sind.
Nicht auf eine Echtzeit äh streamen wirklich laufen können, oder?
Ja, weil also entweder das nicht oder sie haben sowieso eine Lizenz für die Musik oder,
sie schlagen halt nicht schon bei so kurzen Ausschnitten an, weil es ist natürlich auch klar, je kürzer der Ausschnitt, desto größer ist auch die Fehlerquote
Also auch das ist allein schon ein Grund, weshalb also wenn man das mit den Upload-Filtern überhaupt macht, weshalb es irgendwie solche Grenzwerte braucht, weil wenn man sehr kurze,
Ausschnitte sperren das, das sieht man ja in den hundertsechzig Zeichen, dann werden natürlich die ähm Fehlerquoten auch entsprechend höher.
Hm, ja, das äh aber also ich meine, das das kommt mir ein bisschen noch sehr komisch vor. Ich denke da eher an diesen Fall, ähm.
Der YouTube-Anwalt Christian Solmecke hat doch da äh wollte das den Song von Danger Dan ähm besprechen.
Den man bei uns natürlich zur Premiere in voller Qualität komplett hören konnte, weil wir nicht auf Plattformen veröffentlichen, aber das ist ja nur am Rande. Und dem ist es ja dann nicht gelungen, ähm das hinzukriegen, weil.
Äh die Antilopengängen eben hier den Vertrieb über Universal hat und bei Universe oder Universe war das, glaube ich, und die haben natürlich bei denen läuft das automatisch äh mit in die in diese Schiene und ich glaube, dass dann
irgendwie.
Gewesen, aber ja, also jedenfall.
Ja, ich dachte, das wäre eher das Gleiche.
Die Antilopen Gang selber wussten wahrscheinlich nichts davon.
Nein, nein, der Interdan wusste dann nichts von und hat dann auch äh soweit ich das verstanden habe, unmittelbar dann da gesagt, ey, hört auf, ich will das.
Ich will, dass der mein äh Video bespricht und ähm das hat dann auch funktioniert. Es zeigte
glaube ich, also ich glaube, das haben auch alle richtig verstanden, dass das eben die Absurdität der Upload-Filter zeigte und nicht unbedingt jetzt, ne, was eine Boshaftigkeit von ähm von von von der Antilopen Gang oder so.
Ja, aber das ist halt auch das Doofe, weil natürlich ist das immer ein Imageschaden für für so eine Band, wenn sowas passiert. Und man denkt, erstmal immer, dass äh die irgendwie daran Schuld sind. Also es gab auch schon mal so einen Fall
irgendwie mit äh Chrisfield, dem kanadischen Astronaut, der ähm Space Audity auf der internationalen Weltraumstation gespielt hat.
War auch mal zwischendurch gesperrt und dann waren alle sauer auf David Boeder mit dabei hatte, der das explizit erlaubt.
Und Schuld war jemand anders, also das ist halt immer irgendwie so das Problem bei solchen Sachen, dass das auch für die Kreativen nicht gut ist letzten Endes, wenn diese Fehler passieren,
und ähm ja aber ich glaube äh Solmecke ist insofern ein gutes Beispiel, weil das auch nach der deutschen Reform jetzt äh nicht funktionieren würde. Denn ähm
Also ich habe ja gesagt, man kann auch, wenn man quasi über den fünfzehn Sekunden ist, sein äh
Upload als Zitat gekennzeichnen und das war ja in dem Fall ein Zitat, also,
sich ja kritisch mit jeder Textzeile auseinandergesetzt, aber ähm er hat trotzdem hundert Prozent des Lieds verwendet und ähm,
Ja, mutmaßlich erlaubte Nutzung geht halt nur bis maximal fünfzig Prozent. Egal, ob's dadrüber hinaus halt auch erlaubt ist und deshalb äh würde das halt auch.
Weiterhin gesperrt, also insofern ja dieses Ziel tatsächlich Overblocking komplett zu vermeiden,
schafft diese Umsetzung mit Sicherheit nicht, also insofern das ist auch der Grund, also wir von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, wir haben uns natürlich überlegt, was machen wir, wenn das Ding,
verabschiedet wird. Die erste Option wäre natürlich gewesen Verfassungsbeschwerde, aber da haben wir uns gedacht, also es gibt ja bereits,
Ein Verfahren vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof, ob der Artikel siebzehn überhaupt grundrechtskonform ist und das ist unserer Meinung nach auch das Grundrecht rechtliche Kernproblem.
Und deshalb ähm wollen wir auf dieses Urteil abwarten, was wahrscheinlich Anfang nächsten Jahres kommt und wenn.
Der Europäische Gerichtshof sagt, äh Artikel siebzehn ist grundrechtswidrig, dann muss natürlich auch das deutsche Gesetz weg und äh dafür werden wir uns dann einsetzen. Aber was machen wir in der Zwischenzeit? Also wir haben uns gedacht,
bringt relativ wenig jetzt irgendwie eine Verfassungsbeschwerde einzureichen, die verhandelt wird äh äh nachdem,
irgendwie. Also wer noch aussteht, was mit Artikel siebzehn selber ist und stattdessen wollen wir halt ähm.
In der Zwischenzeit jetzt die Maßnahmen gegen Missbrauch in dem Gesetz nutzen, weil ähm steht ja drin, legale Inhalte dürfen nicht gesperrt werden.
Dann steht drin, wenn das doch passiert und zwar wiederholt, dann können Diensteanbieter von nichtkommerziellen Vereinen, die die
Interessen der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer vertreten, auf Unterlassung in Anspruch genommen werden.
Und ja, wer ist so ein Verein, der die Interessen der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer vertritt, also unter anderem die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte? Also das ist jetzt unser Plan. Wir werden solche Fälle sammeln, wie mit äh Solmecke und Dayer Dan,
natürlich ab dem Datum, wo das Ganze in Kraft tritt, also erster August und wenn wir halt sehen, dass es solche systematischen Sperrungen von legalen Inhalten gibt und die Plattformen irgendwie,
keinen Plan haben, das abzustellen. Dann wollen wir von diesem Verbandskarr gerecht Gebrauch machen.
Mhm. Oh und dann jetzt ist er wieder, dann dann geht es gegen die Plattform, ja?
Ja, also es kommt natürlich drauf an. Äh ich habe gesagt vorhin, wenn's falsche Copyright-Claims sind, also äh jemand behauptet, Rechteinhaber zu sein,
ähm wenn er es gar nicht isst, dann kann man auch gegen den Rechtsinhaber direkt klagen, was sich in dem Fall auch wesentlich sinnvoller fände. Aber in diesem Dangerdan-Fall,
Ist ja das Problem,
streng genommen der rechteinhaber ja nicht so richtig was falsch gemacht hat, außer vielleicht moralisch was falsch gemacht hat, indem er überhaupt auf Uploadfilter setzt. Aber er hat ja einfach nur gesagt gegenüber Content ID hier,
Das ist mein Song oder so. Aber die Sperrung ist ja höchstwahrscheinlich automatisch passiert, ohne dass der rechte Inhaber nochmal gefragt wurde. Und deshalb.
Habe ich das auch verstanden, ja, dass.
In in so einer Konstellation kann man natürlich schwer gegen den Rechtsinhaber vorgehen, weil es war ja Danger Dance Song. Also es war nicht so, dass der Upload-Filter das falsche Lied erkannt hat,
sondern das Problem war halt, in diesem Fall hätte nicht automatisch gesperrt werden dürfen.
Ja. Und als es wäre, es ist ja, denke, sehr klar, eine äh ja eine erlaubte Nutzung, ne, oder auch eine intendierte Nutzung.
Genau, genau.
Aber äh jetzt nochmal spannend, du hast gesagt, trotzdem wäre sie gemäß dieser ähm der aktuellen Regelung nicht erlaubt, weil mehr als die Hälfte wieder abgespielt wird.
Nee, man muss unterscheiden zwischen erlaubt und ob man's hochladen kann. Also erlaubt wäre sie.
Aber nach den Regeln, die vorgesehen sind, wie die Upload-Filter funktionieren, werden sie halt trotzdem gesperrt worden. Und das ist das,
absurde eigentlich an diesem Gesetz, dass drinsteht, es darf nichts gesperrt werden, was legal ist und dann wird Regeln aufgestellt, die halt doch dazu führt, dass was gesperrt wird, was legal ist.
Da muss ich echt auch noch mal meinen Kopf drum wickeln. Das ist also, das ist das ist wirklich äh der, der, der primär verwirrende Teil hier dran für mich und ich glaube auch für viele ähm
andere, die ja diese Debatte verfolgen mit anderen Worten, hier gibt es und und also irgendwann werden Gerichte klären müssen, was schwerer wiegt.
Sagen, du darfst nichts Legales sperren oder na ja, hier diese Daumenregeln halten
wenn deine Technik sich hier dran hält, dann muss eben alles, was dann noch erlaubt ist und hier dann in diese Filterregeln fällt, muss eben leider damit leben, dass es eine Extrarunde braucht, bis das Video freigeschaltet wird oder
äh was wären, was glaubst du denn, wären sinnvolle juristische Lösungen des Problems, weil es scheint ja wirklich,
eins zu sein, was also ein Problem zu sein, was nicht lösbar ist.
Naja, also ich glaube, die sinnvolle Regel äh ihr juristische Lösung wäre auf den Uploadfilter zu verzichten. Also das heißt ja nicht,
dass die Plattform unter keinen Umständen für urbarechtlich geschützte Inhalte bezahlen müssen. Ähm
es gibt ja auch Teile von Artikel siebzehn, die sagen, also die Plattformen werden verpflichtet, irgendwie
faire Lizenzangebote anzunehmen. Das könnte man ja durchaus behalten und trotzdem die Pflicht zum Einsatz vom Upload-Filtern streichen. Und streng genommen, also diese Klage,
Europäischen Gerichtshof liegt, die bezieht sich auch streng genommen nur auf die Verpflichtung zum Filtern. Insofern könnte es sogar sein,
ist nicht unbedingt die Wahrscheinlichste ähm Konstellation, dass der Europäische Gerichtshof nur Teile von Artikel siebzehn streicht.
Die quasi den Einsatz von Uploadfiltern betreffen und andere Teile bestehen lässt. Aber also.
Die genau diese Abwägungsfrage ist eigentlich der Kern, der ähm.
Des Verfahrens, das vom Europäischen Gerichtshof liegt, weil sowohl die Meinungsfreiheit als auch äh das geistige Eigentum sind in der,
EU-Grundrechte-Carta geschützt. Und grundsätzlich müssen die erstmal in Einklang miteinander gebracht werden. Also es muss irgendwie ein Ausgleich zwischen den Grundrechten gefunden werden. Und die Frage ist dann eben, also ob quasi dieses Ziel,
stärkeren Schutz des Urheberrechts äh durchzusetzen. Die Mittel heilig, dass dabei eben Inhalte gesperrt werden, die überhaupt nicht gegen das Urheberrecht verstoßen.
Und da ja, das ist äh ich meine, im Zweifelsfall, also ich ich frage mich halt, wie ich äh ab äh wie ich.
Urteilen würde. Im Zweifelsfall hast du Recht, dann lasst halt diese lasst halt die Pflicht zur automatischen Filterung weg. Damit ist schon mal der größere Teil des Problems gelöst. Und dann wäre doch auch das Schöne.
Jetzt wirst du mich korrigieren, wenn ich falsch liege. Wenn man da nämlich nicht die Pflicht zur automatischen Filterung drin hätte, dann wäre man in der Welt, in der wir ja viele Jahre vorher auch gelebt haben.
In der gefiltert wird. Ist ja nicht so, als wäre ein Uploadfilter neu, muss man ja auch sagen, das war ja.
Das ja auch öfter wiederholt. Einer der Teile, die ich halt interessant fand, war, dass jetzt die YouTuber, ausgerechnet die YouTuber, die seit Jahren mit Upload-Filtern leben. Äh so gegen diese äh Reform.
Gelaufen sind. Ähm kann man natürlich die einfache Antwort darauf ist, die wissen, wie Scheiße die sind, ja? Das äh ähm.
Wenn man jetzt diese Pflicht zum Filtern weglässt und wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, ist das eben, die ergibt sich aus dem Artikel siebzehn Frühjahr Artikel dreizehn. Ist denn dann alles gut?
Also alles gut ist im Urheberrecht eigentlich nie. Also es gibt so viele Probleme, Unklarheiten, Ungereimtheiten. Also auch wenn man jetzt einfach sagt,
Plattformen sind verpflichtet, Lizenzen äh einzukaufen, dann wären auch damit noch ganz viele Fragen nicht geklärt, weil dann äh ist immer noch die Frage.
Für welche Plattform ist das eigentlich fair? Also dass man sagt irgendwie YouTube muss für Musik bezahlen
finde ich relativ fair, kann man durchaus machen, aber muss zum Beispiel Tinder in Zukunft Lizenzen
mit den Verwertungsgesellschaften für Fotos abschließen, weil es könnte ja jemand auf die Idee kommen, den Getikalog bei Tinder hochzuladen, würde ich sagen, eher nein. Also ähm das heißt, es gibt immer noch keine so richtige,
gute theoretische Grundlage dafür, um welche Plattformen es überhaupt gehen soll,
und die das ist auch alles andere als geklärt jetzt mit der Reform. Also ich habe ja gerade schon gesagt, völlig unklar, ob Twitter zum Beispiel drunterfällt oder nicht. Insofern, also ich glaube nicht, dass damit dann alles geklärt wäre, aber zumindest ähm.
Denke ich halt, dass von den verpflichtenden Upload-Filtern die größte Gefahr ausgeht. Ähm ironischerweise,
ist natürlich diese Formulierung im Artikel siebzehn das legale Inhalte nicht gesperrt werden dürfen. In gewisser Weise ein Fortschritt gegenüber dem Status Quo. Weil im Moment ist es ja so, Uploadfilter werden eingesetzt.
Werden dabei alle naselang legale Inhalte gesperrt. Das äh Problem ist bloß, man weiß halt nicht, wie ernst.
Die Plattform und auch die Gerichte diese Verpflichtung nehmen werden, also die Musikindustrie sagt halt immer so, na ja, das das soll man nicht so wörtlich nehmen im Artikel siebzehn, das wäre eher so gemeint als äh Regelung,
ähm die im Prinzip nur sagt.
Dauerhaft sollen die Inhalte dann wieder hochgestellt werden und deshalb gibt's ein Beschwerdemechanismus, während halt die EU Kommission sagt, nee, nee, das ist schon so gemeint, wie es da steht, also das quasi noch bevor gesperrt wird,
festgestellt werden muss, ob ein Inhalt legal ist und der muss dann vor der Sperrung geschützt werden. Also das heißt, ähm.
Je nachdem, wie die Gesetze äh am Ende ausgelegt werden, ist halt auch diese Regelung,
legale Inhalte nicht gesperrt werden, durchaus was, was bewahrenswert ist und was vielleicht auch einen Fortschritt darstellen würde.
Mit dem wir auch lange ja eigentlich schon auch ganz gut gefahren sind, ne. Dass das äh dass die Sperrung eben nicht vorher stattfindet. Also das ist ja,
Wir haben das ja hier öfter auch besprochen, eigentlich eines der fundamental Prinzipien ähm bei der Veröffentlichung im Netz ist eben, dass gerade die Plattform, das Privileg haben eben
erstmal davon auszugehen, dass ihre Nutzerinnen nichts Böses im Schilde führen. Und wenn sie davon Kenntnis erlangen.
Dass die Nutzerinnen etwas Böses im Schilde führen, dass sie dann äh in dem Moment die Haftung äh tragen ähm mit,
in dem Moment, wo sie davon Kenntnis erlangen, eben mit verantwortlich sind, was im Prinzip dazu führt, dass die Rechteinhaberinnen einen kurzen Weg haben zu sagen, hier Mainz, weg. Und ähm.
Eigentlich nicht besonders tragisch auch für ja, wenn wir wieder in den Bereich des Textes gehen, auch die die äh was weiß ich, Ehrverletzenden Inhalte oder sonst was, wenn jemand ein Forum anbietet oder eine Kommentarfunktion unter A,
das war ja dann dieser gesamte Bereich, der eben im Rahmen der nochmal diskutiert wurde.
Unbedingt im Rahmen des Urheberrechtes, sondern eben dann auch hier im Bereich der ja, letztendlich politischen Meinungsfreiheit, ne.
Ja, also äh äh ich denke auch, wir sind lange gut damit gefahren, dass man erstmal alles hochladen kann, aber auch das ändert sich
jetzt bereits also YouTube hat vor kurzem ein neues Feature eingeführt und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das quasi in.
Vorbereitung auf die Umsetzung des deutschen Gesetzes war.
Ähm sie nennen es ein Feature, man kann sich drüber streiten, ob's wirklich eine Verbesserung ist, dass man jetzt quasi noch bevor man,
den Inhalt hochlädt, informiert wird, wenn da ein drauf ist. Und das ist auch das, was äh Christian Solmecke passiert ist, mit dem Danger Dan Video, der konnte es gar nicht erst hochladen. Und YouTube argumentiert, na ja, das ist eine Dienstleistung an,
die User, dass sie halt im Vorfeld schon wissen, wenn da ein Problem ist, damit der Inhalt nicht erst online geht, ein paar Views einsammelt und angesperrt wird.
Dann haben sie sich die ganze Arbeit gemacht und dann ist ihre Kampagne kaputt oder so, also das ist quasi die.
Argumentation, warum das gut ist, aber die die Gegenargumentation ist halt, dass dann auch ein Inhalt.
Gar nicht erst viral gehen kann und du weißt dann gar nicht, dass er gesperrt wurde. Also das weiß nur die Person, die versucht hat, ihn hochzuladen und Christian Solmecke hat jetzt halt das Glück, dass seine große Reichweite hat und deshalb eben dann halt ein neues Video gemacht hat und gesagt hat, hier,
mir ist was total lustiges passiert, nämlich der Uploadfilter hat mir ein legales Zitat gesperrt und konnte damit so viel Aufmerksamkeit erregen, dass Danger Dan das dann auch mitgekriegt hat. Aber wenn du halt einfach irgendwie weniger Reichweite hast, dann,
Merkt's halt einfach keiner mehr, dass legale Inhalte gesperrt werden.
Dann
stellt sich mir noch die andere Frage, die ich auch immer ein bisschen unterdiskutiert fand, deswegen haben wir uns, ich habe gerade das rausgesucht, äh ich glaube, zwanzig achtzehn als äh CCC mal dazu geäußert, dass
so einen Uploadfilter muss ja auch erstmal bauen, ne? Und der ist ja
überhaupt nicht trivial. Also die Datenmengen, mit denen der umgehen muss, ineffizienter Weise mit ähm
sehr geringen Fehlertoleranzen, das ist wirklich eine enorme Sache. Eine spannende Herausforderung, von der wir wissen.
Ne, von der man ohne großartig davon Ahnung zu haben, sofort sehen kann, dass sie nicht äh perfekt gelöst werden kann.
Das heißt, es ist eigentlich sehr naheliegend, dass äh neue, junge, kleine Plattformen
ähm sich, sofern sie unter einen Uploadfilter Zwang fallen, ähm denen lieber von Dritten einkaufen oder bereitstellen lassen als äh ja diese,
Problemfabrik nochmal selber zu betreiben.
Jetzt äh wir haben beim letzten Mal schon auch darüber gesprochen, dass es potenzielle Ausnahmen für kleine, junge, neue,
Start-up Plattformen gibt, dass die nicht sofort damit belastet werden, was es aus solchen Ausnahmen geworden.
Also die Ausnahmen sind noch drin. Ich glaube, ich muss auch mal einen allgemeinen Disclaimer äh machen, seit wir das letzte Mal gesprochen haben, der Bundestag hat fast nur Verbesserungen an dem Gesetz vorgenommen. Das hat mich auch ein bisschen überrascht.
Eine zentrale Verschlechterung und zwar, dass jetzt eben bestimmte äh.
Ausschnitte aus Live-Content, also vor allen Dingen Fußball spielen, aber auch.
Filmen, die bisher noch nicht gelaufen sind, äh während der Erstausstrahlung, also während das Fußballspiel noch läuft, überhaupt nicht gepostet werden dürfen. Also das heißt, du kannst kein vom Tor aus einem Fußballspiel hochladen, während das noch läuft.
Auch wenn es streng genommen alle Kriterien von mutmaßlich erlaubten Nutzung erfüllt. Das ist natürlich Mist. Das ist natürlich offensichtlich auf äh den den Mist von irgendwie DFB und DFL und den anderen äh Fußball,
Lobbyisten gewachsen, aber das ist die einzige Verschlechterung,
der Bundestag verabschiedet hat, ansonsten hat sich gegenüber dem Regierungsentwurf.
Der das Gesetz eigentlich nur verbessert. Also es gibt ähm es wurden irgendwie Einschränkungen der.
Ausnahme für Karikatur, Parodie und Pastiv gestrichen, das führt dazu, dass in Zukunft irgendwie Remix und.
Und Memes und so weiter in Deutschland erstmalig legal sind. Äh es wurden.
Neue, also es wurden so ein paar Anreize gestrichen für Plattformen, zu viel zu sperren. Also vorher war irgendwie vorgesehen, dass die Plattform für alle Urheberrechtsausnahmenvergütungen bezahlen müssen. Das ist ja jetzt nur noch für,
Karitaturparodie und Pastis der Fall. Also das heißt, äh die Probleme.
Sind größtenteils nicht durch den Bundestag entstanden, sondern all die Probleme, die es halt mit dem Regierungsentwurf gab, über den wir vor kurzem gesprochen haben, sind halt immer noch da.
Aber.
Das finde ich ja, das finde ich ja schön und gut, dass du das mal benennst. Jetzt ist aber kurz erklären, das mit den Fußballvermarkungs äh oder mit den Fußball Live-Aufnahmen, ne, also wer das verfolgt, weiß,
das Recht Fußballspiele bestimmter Ligen leicht
live zu übertragen wird zu enormen Preisen versteigert. Und ähm entsprechend mit mit äh zu hohen Werbe.
Pausenpreisen ähm vermarktet oder die die öffentlich-rechtlichen müssen sich dafür rechtfertigen, dass sie was weiß ich, die WM oder die Champions League oder sowas
kauft haben. Wo haben die jetzt überhaupt einen Urheberrechtsanspruch her? An dem Tor von Lionel Messi.
Das ist eine ausgezeichnete Frage, weil es gibt keinen Leistungsschutzrecht für Sportveranstaltungen. Also das heißt, das einzige Recht, was die eigentlich haben,
ist äh das Recht der Fernsehsender. Also die machen das halt so, die lassen einfach nur einen Fernsehsender in ins Stadion.
Dann halt filmen, das machen die wahrscheinlich übers Hausrecht oder so. Und dieser Sender hat dann an seinen Aufnahmen ein Leistungsschutzrecht.
Und das ist quasi das Recht, was sie dann nutzen, um,
Ausschnitte aus dieser offiziellen Aufnahme damit zu sperren. Also das heißt, wenn du selber im Stadion stehst und auf deinem Handy filmst, das darf also das sollte davon nicht betroffen sein, sondern es geht wirklich um Ausschnitte aus der offiziellen Aufzeichnung.
Und ähm ich halte das aber trotzdem für großen Quatsch, weil letzten Endes,
also illegale Livestreams sind ja sowieso keine mutmaßliche erlaubten Nutzung, das heißt also ähm.
Die würden von dieser fünfzehn Sekunden Regel überhaupt nicht profitieren. Äh höchstens irgendwie,
also Ausschnitte, die ich selber noch mal verändert habe und die kürzer als fünfzehn Sekunden sind kämmen überhaupt in Frage. Also das heißt wirklich das klassische Fußballturmi vielleicht.
Da denke ich mir wirklich, was ist der große Schaden? Also ich glaube nicht, dass Fußballfans irgendwie weniger Geld für Fußball ausgeben, weil sie Memes posten können. Ganz im Gegenteil. Also die Leute gehen doch irgendwie ins Stadion und,
Geld für Fußballausweis ihnen Spaß macht und wenn man sich dann die ganze Zeit so gegängelt fühlt, also ich finde, das ist wieder so wie wie mit der Super League, dass halt irgendwie die,
Konzernchefs bei diesem Fußballverbänden versuchen, noch ein bisschen mehr Geld rauszuholen, aber eigentlich sich damit äh ins eigene Fleisch schneiden.
Also mir kann, mir kommt das wirklich, also äh urheberrecht kann ich da überhaupt nicht drin erkennen und also das Einzige, was ich hier sehe, ist, dass ja schon relevante Spiele,
oder oder Spiele, die die Leute interessieren sehr gerne bei irgendwelchen Pay-TV-Sendern landen und die haben natürlich kein Bock drauf,
Ja, erstens, dass es ein illegale weiter Streaming Sachen gibt, klar, dass es eine Sache und die haben natürlich auch ein Interesse daran, dass diese, wenn diese Leute schon ihre ganzen illegalen Weiterstreams machen, dass sie die wenigstens nicht auf Twitch und YouTube machen. Soweit kann ich
der ganzen Sache noch folgen. Ähm.
Wenn jetzt aber, also mein, so ein Fußballfan, ja, wenn die da jetzt irgendwie sitzen und die können das Spiel nicht gucken, ja
und dann können die demnächst auf Facebook noch nicht mal oder ne, oder bei YouTube oder wo auch immer, noch nicht mal das Tor sehen. Ich sehe ja den Tim als Fußballfan, wie nervös der wird, wenn der äh die Union spielte nicht gucken kann, ne? Weil,
und das verliert ja auch hm das denke ich, muss man ja echt auch dazu sagen, das verliert ja die haben ja eine ähm.
Eine unglaubliche Halbwertszeit, weil kein Mensch versuchen kann, zu sagen, ich ich ähm ich gucke, dass äh Endspiel der Fußball Weltmeisterschaft nicht heute Abend, sondern ich gucke das morgen früh und versuche, mich in einen Nachrichten,
Loch zu werfen, dass sich's dann nicht mehr weiß. Ja und,
ich die Person, die dann im Radio hört, hier äh so und so hat ein Tor geschossen und sagt, boah, Wahnsinn und fährt irgendwie auf der Autobahn raus, auf der Raststätte,
das Handy und will auf Facebook kurz,
wie wie das äh eins null geschossen wird und kann das nicht finden. Ähm ja, das erscheint mir tatsächlich eine eine.
Nicht nachvollziehbare.
Es ist Gängelung der eigenen Fans. Also anders kann man das eigentlich nicht beschreiben. Und das Schlimme ist natürlich, dass das dann jetzt nicht nur für Fußball gelten wird, sondern für halt jegliche,
Erstausstrahlung. Und das fand ich ganz interessant. Ich war die Tage im ARD-Studio und habe das auch mit einem SPD-Abgeordneten
diskutiert und da meinte die Moderatorin, auf die Idee war ich noch gar nicht gekommen, ja das heißt dann aber auch,
dass ich Angst haben muss, also wenn ich jetzt quasi aus einer Plenardebatte so einen Ausschnitt rausschneide.
Und die Plenardebatte läuft noch und die laufen ja manchmal vierundzwanzig Stunden am Stück,
dann könnte das halt theoretisch gesperrt werden. Und dann hat er halt gesagt, na ja, aber das würde, würde das Parlamentsfernsehen ja nie so tun sozusagen.
Aber der Punkt ist halt, sie können es, also das ist auch leider so ein ein ganz große Baustelle, die bei dieser Urheberrechtsreform nicht angegangen wurde, dass der Staat.
Ähm oder staatlich erstellte Werke immer noch nicht automatisch gemeinfrei sind. Also das gilt nur für ganz Wenige.
Offizielle Dokumente bisher halt irgendwie Gesetzestexte und so weiter, dass die ganz klar gemeinfrei sind, aber es ist natürlich logisch, dass eigentlich alles,
was im im Rahmen der öffentlichen Aufgaben erstellt wird, also Plenarsitzung, Parlamentsdokumente, irgendwelche Memos, die in Ministerien geschrieben werden, das muss alles nicht urheberrechtlich geschützt sein, weil die Leute.
Haben wir bezahl.
Werden ja alle bezahlt, also.
Das ist meins.
Ist leider immer noch nicht passiert. Ich hoffe, dass das noch kommt, weil das ist ja auch für Open Data ein Riesenproblem. Also gerade die Tage war das ja wieder in den Nachrichten, dass da irgendwie diese.
Gesperrt werden von irgendwelchen Open Data, ähm Aktivistin, weil halt irgendein.
Amt in Bayern jetzt der Meinung ist, dass sie Urheberrecht an irgendwelchen Daten geltend machen müssen, die äh also Kartografiedaten und solche Sachen. Und das finde ich einfach unmöglich. Also.
Fand ich gut, dass das dann auch die Presse irgendwie mal kritisch anmerkt, weil die trifft das ja auch. Also wenn der Staat irgendwie versucht, das Urheberrecht zu nutzen, um ähm.
Quasi Informationen in der öffentlichen Hand aus der Öffentlichkeit zu halten, dann ist das ja auch für die Pressefreiheit ein Problem und dann bin ich froh, dass die da ausnahmsweise auch mal sensibel für sind.
Zu den Fußballübertragungen noch eine letzte Frage.
Müssen wir jetzt damit rechnen, dass es irgendwelche Twitcher gibt, die jetzt äh mit ihrer Kamera zu den äh zu den Spielen gehen und die ihr ihr iPhone hochhalten und dann sagen, ah, werfen wir noch fünf Euro in in äh in Topf,
Das würden im Zweifelsfall die Stadien dann, wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe über Hausordnung regeln, ne?
Also müssten sie, weil äh übers Urheberrecht können sie es nicht regeln. Da gibt's schon ein Urteil, Hartplatzhelden vom Bundesgerichtshof,
klargestellt wurde und deshalb lobbyieren die Sportverbände jetzt allen Ernstes für ein Leistungsschutzrecht für Sportveranstalter auf EU-Ebene, aber bisher gibt's das noch nicht.
Oh Mann, die haben es auch echt nötig, ne? Da kann auch echt kein, äh da wundert man sich doch, äh wirklich nicht mehr, dass die mit ihren Superligen
einfach nur auf einen schweren, großen, dicken Mittelfinger prallen und die Leute inzwischen sagen, komm, ey, äh ich gucke mir, was weiß ich, ne, dritte, vierte Liga an, Regionalliga, bei mir vor der,
vor der Haustür, die sind auch sportlicher als ich und äh und Bier ist günstiger, ne? Also kann ich schon verstehen.
Ja und man wird nicht irgendwie als kriminelle.
Betrachtet, weil man irgendwie sein Geld für ein Hobby ausgeben will. Also.
Unglaublich. Also wir haben, wir halten fest, ähm von dem großen Schadenspotenzial.
Was der Bundesregierungsentwurf war, gibt es bis auf diese Fußballsache, im weiteren parlamentarischen Prozess nur Verbesserungen. Das heißt aber nicht, dass der kaputte Rahmen, der eben aus der EU.
Richtlinie kommt, repariert werden konnte, bei denen konnte man ja nicht mehr reparieren, weil er ist jetzt eine EU-Richtlinie.
Deswegen geht eine andere Organisation, du hast den Namen nicht genannt, da habe ich vergessen nachzufragen, auf EU-Ebene schon gegen Artikel äh siebzehn vor.
Also diese andere Organisation ist äh äh dummerweise die Regierung von Polen,
und die sind jetzt natürlich nicht gerade für den Schutz der Grundrechte bekannt, aber das war halt so, also es gab sieben Mitgliedstaaten in der EU, die gegen Artikel siebzehn gestimmt haben. Polen war halt einer davon und es war kurz vor der Europawahl,
Also haben die einfach schnell,
Klage eingereicht, also das dürfen Mitgliedsstaaten, die dürfen unmittelbar in äh äh in Luxemburg gegen solche ähm EU-Richtlinien klagen,
zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen können das nicht. Die können nicht unmittelbar nach Luxemburg gehen.
Ah, okay.
Und deshalb musste das quasi von einem Mitgliedstaat ausgehen und äh ja, Polen hat dummerweise einen Alleingang gemacht, also die haben sich auch nicht mit den anderen Mitgliedsstaaten, die vielleicht irgendwie einen besseren demokratischen Track Record haben, abgesprochen,
auch dagegen waren, sondern sind halt einfach äh mit ihrer äh Klage vorgeprescht.
Es ist mir jetzt natürlich also gut, dass es die gibt auf der einen Seite, weil dadurch zumindest relativ schnell,
Eine Klärung herbeigeführt wird, aber gleichzeitig ist es auch ein bisschen ungünstig, weil Polen relativ wenige Aspekte in seine Klage eingebracht hat. Also die stützen sich nur auf die Verletzung der Meinungsfreiheit,
und haben zum Beispiel also solche Dinge wie unternehmerische Freiheit, Privatsphäre und andere Folgen von Artikel siebzehn nicht beleuchtet, Kunstfreiheit.
Ähm und eben, wie gesagt, sie klagen auch nur gegen einen Teil von Artikel siebzehn, nämlich den Einsatz von Upload-Filtern.
Aber genau, also das heißt mit der Einreichung dieser Klage hatte die Zivilgesellschaft nichts zu tun, weil sie nicht klageberechtigt war,
aber die liegt jetzt natürlich vor. Wir beteiligen uns natürlich trotzdem an der,
Debatte um diese Klage, also die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte hat dazu auch äh eine Studie veröffentlicht. Aber das Urteil dazu wird eben relativ bald schon, also zumindest in,
für die Verhältnisse von Gerichten relativ bald wahrscheinlich Anfang nächsten Jahres vorliegen. Und ähm ja, darauf warten wir gespannt.
Währenddessen konzentriert ihr euch ab dem ersten August, wenn der ganze Kram in Kraft tritt, auf,
ähm dass ja so Verbandsklagerecht quasi bei Maßnahmen
gegen den Missbrauch bei äh wiederholter Sperrung und freut euch, wenn euch Betroffene
von von Unrechtmäßigen Sperrungen in Kenntnis setzen, damit ihr da als GFF entsprechend äh strategisch gegen vorgehen könnt.
Genau, also wir haben dafür eine äh Adresse eingerichtet, Uploadfilter at Freiheitsrechte Punkt org. Kann man sich hoffentlich gut merken,
und dort kann man einfach uns schreiben, also wenn ihr von äh Sperrung, legaler Inhalte auf den Plattformen betroffen seid, vor allen Dingen ab dem ersten August, aber wir sind dann natürlich auch äh vorher schon über Hinweise dankbar,
und wie gesagt, also es gibt da dann verschiedene Möglichkeiten vorzugehen, es gibt Möglichkeiten gegen falsche Copyright Claims vorzugehen, also direkt gegen die angeblichen Rechteinhaber,
und es gibt eben auch die Möglichkeit gegen Plattformen vorzugehen, wenn also systematisch ähm legale Inhalte gesperrt werden oder wiederholt steht im Gesetz.
Alles klar, damit haben wir alles zur Urheberrechtsreform gesagt.
Genau, also.
Dann müssen wir noch ganz kurz.
Jetzt auch länger geworden als gedacht.
Ja, ist ja gar kein Thema. Wir wissen doch über eine Kleinigkeit sprechen. Es ist ja gerade die Republika und du hast einen äh Vortrag gehalten heute,
mit Markus Becker zusammen. Ich äh glaube Markus auch von zu Hause aus, genau wie du. Die zweite virtuelle Republika oder ist es ja, es ist noch die zweite, ne?
Genau, also wir sind ins Studio gegangen so schön mit Schnelltests und so weiter und haben das vorher aufgezeichnet, aber heute läuft es auf dem Republika Programm.
Da habt ihr euch mit den äh Netzsperren auseinandergesetzt, die ja auch wieder kommen. Also es ist.
Ja
Was ist da passiert? Wir haben's im Lokbuch schon behandelt, aber ich weiß, dass du auch in deine heiße Kolumne darüber gesprochen hast und jetzt äh bei der Republika äh die CUI.
Genau, also ich nenne sie Queen
weiß nicht, ob sich das äh durchsetzen wird. Es ist die Clearing-Stelle Urheberrecht im Internet und das ist de facto also eine ein privates Gremium zur Verhängung von DNS-Sperren. Und dieses Gremium
besteht eben aus den üblichen Verdächtigen der Rechteinhaberverbände, also Bundesverband Musikindustrie, ähm.
Die.
Also so Filmindustrie, Musikindustrie, äh Verlage, also vor allen Dingen die Wissenschaftsverlage an der Stelle tun sich zusammen mit äh allen großen Internetprovidern in Deutschland.
Und ähm beschließen eben in diesem Gremium, in einer privaten Absprache, welche.
Strukturell urgerechtsverletzenden Webseiten, wenn sie das gesperrt werden sollen. Und ähm das Problem dabei ist, also.
DNS-Sperren gibt's zwar jetzt schon länger in Deutschland, dass halt Gerichte,
die Sperrung von bestimmten Webseiten anordnen, aber das Problem bei diesem Verfahren ist, dass dadurch die Gerichte nicht mehr angerufen werden. Bisher war's halt so, die ähm,
Internetprovider haben sich in aller Regel geweigert, äh einfach Netzsperren vorzunehmen. Das müssen sie eigentlich ja auch, weil äh die,
Netzneutralitätsverordnung auch sagt, man darf nicht willkürlich irgendwelche Webseiten sperren,
und ähm also das heißt bisher, wenn Rechtsinhaber auf sie zukam, gesagt haben, hier sperrt diese Webseite wegen Urgerichtsverletzung, haben die das nicht gemacht, sondern haben halt gesagt, ja verklagt uns doch.
Und.
Da haben sie aber häufiger verloren und wollten in jetzt eben die Gerichtskosten sparen, nehme ich an und haben also gesagt, okay, in Zukunft machen wir das freiwillig nach diesem Verfahren der und das Problem,
entsteht dabei halt nicht nur oder nicht in erster Linie für die Internet Provider, sondern für die Betroffenen, also für die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer und auch die Webseitenbetreiber,
die jetzt einfach nicht mehr also deren Interessen nicht mehr in einem Gerichtsverfahren abgewogen werden.
Und für die User ist das halt vor allen Dingen ein Problem, wenn auf solchen Webseiten eine Mischung von legalen und illegalen Inhalten angeboten wird. Und da war's halt bisher so, dass dann ein Gericht,
Eine Grundrechtsabwägung vornehmen musste.
Die Sperrung angesichts der Einschnitte in die Informationsfreiheit, die dadurch entstehen, dass da halt auch legale Inhalte abrufbar sind, gerechtfertigt ist. Und das fällt jetzt halt weg.
Ähm ja, also ziemlich problematisch, wenn man bedenkt, dass in der Vergangenheit auch eine.
Ähm gesetzesbasierte oder oder richterlich angeordnete Netzsperre durchaus kontrovers war, dass das jetzt eben komplett ohne Richtervorbehalt passiert.
Ist da irgendjemand vertreten, wo man erwarten könnte, dass die Person gegen die Sperrung stimmt?
Naja, die Internet haben jetzt zumindest kein gesteigertes Interesse daran, Webseiten zu sperren. Also ich glaube, wenn jetzt komplett.
Abwegige Forderungen kommen würden von Sperrungen, dann würden wahrscheinlich die Internetprovider nein sagen. Ähm ich mache mir vor allen Dingen Sorgen um solche Fälle, wie zum Beispiel Saihab, also wo ähm.
Auf der einen Seite die also zum Beispiel die Wissenschaftsverlage in der Kuh sitzen und auf werden ja.
Ja sehr, sehr viele wissenschaftliche Artikel, die sonst hinter einer Paywall sind, ähm zum Download-Angeboten. Und ähm ich glaube, alle, die sich irgendwie mit der wissenschaftlichen Publikationslandschaft auskennen, wissen halt.
Dass ähm.
Urheberinnen und Urheber, also die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler von diesem der Durchsetzung der Urheberrechte an ihren Werken überhaupt nichts haben. Also im Gegenteil, die werden vom Staat dafür bezahlt,
dass sie forschen, äh diese wissenschaftliche Forschung aufschreiben
und die dann kostenfrei an Wissenschaftsverlage geben, die dir dann teuer wie die wieder an die Universitäten zurückverkaufen.
Ja, ist absolutes Wahnsinns-Assi-Modell. Seit seit Jahrzehnten.
Also eigentlich äh äh völlig unethisch und man kann sich natürlich auch drüber.
Unterhalten, ob man dagegen nicht irgendwie vorgehen müsste. Aber das ist halt erstmal so der Status quo und da hat natürlich so eine Webseite wie Cyhab.
Die ähm eben diese geschützten Artikel dann trotzdem ohne Paywall anbietet, eine große Bedeutung. Und ich weiß nicht, ob sich die.
Internet-Provider jetzt irgendwie für.
Open Access, Wissenschaft und äh irgendwie die Aufbrechung dieser Knebelverträge einsetzen werden und dann in die Bresche springen für so eine Webseite wie Cyhab. Das ist mal eine Sorge an der Stelle.
Ja, also sollte man auf jeden Fall nochmal betonen, ich verlinke in den auch, es gibt da im Moment eine ähm
Rettungsaktion zu Cyhab, wo man darum gebeten wird, von irgendwelchen redet Leuten
das sollte man natürlich nicht tun, wenn man nicht über eine saubere VPN Verbindung verfügt, von der man auch sicher geht, dass der Torant nicht weitergesiedelt wird, wenn das VPN wegfällt. Ähm A
äh äh andererseits höre ich auch umgekehrt, dass es wohl nicht so dramatisch um Seihab stünde, sondern viel eher,
potentiell um die äh Gründerin oder das Gesicht von, deren Nachnamen ich so schlecht aussprechen kann, Alexandra ähm.
Liege ich da jetzt falsch.
Ja, ich glaube.
Ne? Ja, also die hat äh im Anfang Mai,
gezeigt, dass das FBI zum Beispiel auf ihre äh Gmail Daten zugegriffen hat. Also das ist nee, auf ihre Apple-Daten, also sie hat von
Apple, Privacy, 'ne Mail bekommen, übrigens hier das FBI hat alle deine Daten angefordert, wir sagen's dir jetzt, zwei Jahre später, weil wir es dir jetzt sagen dürfen, ne, weil
wir damit nicht mehr äh interpieren mit dem.
Ermittlungsverfahren und da muss man ja wirklich sagen, sie hat, also spielt, wie du gerade schon betont hast, eine eine ganz besondere Rolle für Forscherinnen, die,
grade mal, also vielleicht auch einfach nur zwischen Jobs sind oder im Homeoffice. Ja, ich ich erinnere mich aus meiner Zeit an der Universität, du konntest mit einer Uni-Adresse ähm dir diese Artikel runterladen.
Machen aber wenn du halt zu Hause sahst, dann ging es eben schon nicht mehr, also hast du halt irgendwie mit einem VPN gearbeitet und wenn du jetzt auf einmal äh wie viele an den Universitäten prekär beschäftigte Personen mal zwischenjobs bis,
waren ein viertel Jährchen äh nicht beschäftigt, weil du wieder gefeuert wurdest, damit du nicht zu lange angestellt.
Ähm in solchen Situationen ist das natürlich äh von enormer Bedeutung oder sei es nur, dass eine wichtige für deinen Forschungszweig wichtige,
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnis bei einem Verlag veröffentlicht wurde. Ähm
auf den du aufgrund deiner universitären Einbindung grade mal keinen Zugang hast, ne? Und.
Ja, absolut.
Da ist wirklich rechtlich gesehen, ist klar, wie du sagst, eine eine massive Urheberrechtsverletzung, aber es ist eine,
die äh eine aus Notwehr und ich äh denke, dass das das alles, was hier Else Vier und so, das sind
das sind die falschen, das sind die Bösen und da teile ich natürlich deine Sorge, ähm
die werden alles tun, um ihr äh Blut in beide Seiten melken des Geschäftsmodell beizubehalten, wäre es ja auch blöd, wenn es nicht tun würdest, wenn du irgendwie einerseits kostenlose Inhalte geliefert
kommst und von den gleichen Leuten, die dir die Inhalte liefern, dann auch noch Geld nimmst, dass sie die wiederbekommen, äh so ein Geschäftsmodell würde ich auch verteidigen. Hätte hast du ja auch viel Geld übrig,
weil du ja so gut wie keine Kosten hast. Ähm deshalb, ja, also über diese Geschichte wollten wir,
in einer weiteren Sendung nochmal sprechen
erstaunlich, auf was das für eine Datenmenge ist. Also ich habe gedacht, ach ja, okay, dann sieht es da halt mal ab, äh aber die sind.
Das irgendwie fünf Terabyte.
Nee, achtundsiebzig Terabyte oder siebenundachtzig oder so, steht da. Also ist schon ein bisschen größer.
Aber also das ist jetzt natürlich irgendwie so ein äh.
Ein mögliches Worst Case Szenario, aber ich glaube, es ist auch irgendwie ein grundsätzliches Problem mit der Kui, ne? Weil ähm zunehmend werden ja auch die Internetprovider selber zu Streaming-Anbietern. Also bisher wurden.
Äh Streaming-Angebote gesperrt und ähm.
Beim Telekom hat irgendwie sein Magenta und so und das heißt also eigentlich entscheiden da auch Konkurrenten,
zu Streaming-Angeboten darüber, ob quasi das mit ihnen konkurrierende Streaming-Angebot illegal ist oder nicht.
Und die sagen jetzt natürlich, na ja, wir wir sperren nur die ganz klaren Fälle, aber trotzdem ist das natürlich eine katellrechtlich extrem.
Ähm.
Problematische Situation, ne, also dass da quasi die einen Streaming-Anbieter darüber entscheiden, dass die anderen Streaming-Anbieter illegal sind und gesperrt werden müssen. Und deshalb habe ich mal angefangen, mich mit dem Bundeskartellamt zu unterhalten
die ähm.
Eben äh in der in der Lage wären, das Ganze zu stoppen. Und ich habe denen gesagt, na ja, also es gibt auch ein Urteil des Europäischen Gerichtshofs, in dem gesagt wurde, also Wettbewerber dürfen nicht,
darüber entscheiden, wie ihr das eben ein Mitbewerber von ihnen illegal handelt. Das ist die Aufgabe der Gerichte. Und da haben die mehr oder weniger gesagt, ja, das ist ihnen schon bewusst,
und sie sehen das Ganze auch kritisch, aber sie haben im Rahmen ihres Ermessens entschieden, jetzt erstmal nicht gegen die einzuschreiten,
weil, und das fand ich so witzig, also sie sagen, weil, naja, wenn was schiefgeht, dann werden ja bestimmt die die Beschwerden bei uns eingehen.
Dann werden wir dagegen vorgehen, so ungefähr. Also das heißt, der Aufruf an euch alle da draußen, dass genau im Auge zu behalten, dass quasi das Bundeskartellamt offenbar nur darauf wartet, dass es schief geht,
um dann eben doch äh das ganze Wettbewerbsrechtlich zu verbieten. Also finde ich eine interessante Vorgehensweise, aber zumindest sind die sehr offen.
Und ehrlich in ihrer Einschätzung des Ganzen und verschweigen auch nicht die Gefahren. Also die haben mir durchaus auch geschrieben, ähm.
Dass es bei diesem Konstrukt halt die Gefahr gibt, einer Überdehnung und Sperrung auch recht rechtmäßiger Hinweise. Äh äh auch rechtmäßiger Inhalte.
Und das finde ich schon interessant, also dass im Prinzip selbst das Bundeskartenamt sagt, also wir wir würden jetzt nicht so weit gehen zu sagen, dass das rechtmäßig ist, was die hier machen, aber wir tolerieren es vorerst.
Also da
so so etwas sollte also irgendwie eine privatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung in der Infrastruktur, in Richtung Sperrung das ist also das selbst wenn das alles astrein laufen würde
sollte man so was einfach nicht haben.
Also ich finde das auch letzten Endes die Entscheidung des Kartellamts kann ich nicht so richtig nachvollziehen. Also die hätten alle Instrumente an der Hand, um zu sagen, wir unterbinden das.
Und sie sagen halt lieber Weight and Sea. Aber immerhin, also besser als die Bundesnetzagentur, die ist ja auch beteiligt an der ganzen Sache.
Stimmt, die haben ja sogar.
Werbekampagnen dafür. Also die machen irgendwie so Social Media Videos, um zu erklären, wie toll die Kuh ist, also.
Ja, das das war wirklich absolut absurd. Okay, Julia.
Dann es ist Freitagabend, nein, ach, sind morgen natürlich und ähm du hast äh sicherlich ein Interview-Marathon hinter dir
Ähm und natürlich jetzt mit dem Sammeln von Beschwerdefällen und dem strategischen Vorgehen ab August auch noch eine ganze Menge vor dir.
Deshalb danke ich dir, dass du dir so viel Zeit für uns genommen hast nochmal alles zu rekapitulieren und zu erklären.
Und äh wünsche dir auch weiterhin viel Erfolg im im Beackern dieses Themenfeldes.
Ja, vielen, vielen Dank. Also nochmal äh Uploadfilter at Freiheitsrechte Punkt org. Wenn ihr gesperrt werdet. Vielen Dank, äh dass ich hier nochmal meine äh Arbeit vorstellen durfte und ich glaube.
Wohl oder Übel wird uns das Thema Urheberrecht weiter begleiten und dann komme ich euch gern mal wieder besuchen.
Äh ich äh werde es ist jetzt schwierig zu sagen, ich freue mich drauf. Ähm ich freue mich natürlich immer, aber auch wenn du vielleicht am meisten würde ich mich freuen, wenn du was Gutes zu berichten hast. Und es war ja, es war ja heute mal so, so ein ganz kleines bisschen auch was Gutes dabei.
Genau, also immerhin Fan-Fiction ist jetzt legal in Deutschland, das ist doch schon mal ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung.
Wunderbar. Julia, ich wünsche dir ein schönes Pfingstwochenende. Weißt du warum fünf warum man Pfingsten feiert? Ich auch nicht, ich auch nicht. Äh ist mir auch völlig egal. Tschau, tschau.
Äh ja, nee. Alles klar. Mach's gut.